start your business part-time one of my
favorite strategies if you're just
getting started with your company and
start part-time don't go and quit your
job and jump into this company full-time
only to realize that three months later
you've run out of cash and have to go
back and beg for your job this comes as
a result of a question from Twitter
follower
Ahlan or who wrote in to say Evan can we
start a business while we're currently
working for other people and the answer
is absolutely now I've created a zuga
guide that walks you through kind of
step by step how to find the right
company to work for and then how to
actually get started on your own but let
me kind of summarize that entire guide
for you in some of the action steps for
you okay the first thing is if you're
going to be working for somebody if
you're gonna take a job you want a job
where you're gonna learn okay you don't
want a job just to make money
you want a job that's gonna teach you
the skills you need to be a better
entrepreneur and get a job at a company
that does a small company somebody who
you want to be in a few years somebody
who has maybe ten employees where you
can get close to the entrepreneur and
you can learn from them and you could
take on more projects every entrepreneur
is stressed out needs people to help
them needs good people and if you are
motivated dedicated employee who comes
and says hey I'd like to help out with
something else with more they're gonna
give you responsibilities
okay get closer entreprenuer the
business learn the ropes it's important
because if you do just go out and start
your company you're probably not gonna
last because too many entrepreneurs just
run out of cash they run out of money
and they have to go back and get their
old job better to realize that starting
the business takes time you need time
for momentum to build and to grow and
you can do that part-time while you
still are having a job and getting paid
and use the knowledge connections
experience that you get from your job
and make you better when you launch your
company the great thing about working
for somebody else while you're launching
your business is you're getting paid to
make mistakes you're getting paid by
somebody else to not only learn the
business
but to also make your mistakes you're
making mistakes working for somebody
else so that when you go and do your own
thing you dramatically reduce the number
of mistakes you're gonna make when it's
really important right when it's for you
the other thing it will teach you is is
this business for you or not a lot of
entrepreneurs start a business and they
think this is going to be a great idea
and then once they get into it they
realize I really shouldn't have done
that you know I'm not loving and it
wasn't what I thought it was gonna be
and so you can really reduce your risk
and and how much money you're spending
by going out and getting the job in the
field learn how the field works and see
if you like it see if this is still
something that you want to do because
even if you have huge energy and
excitement at the beginning you never
know until you actually get into it so
try it and and working for somebody for
six months or a year is not going to
kill you you've been doing it your whole
life okay it will not kill you to do
another six or 12 months working for
somebody who you admire who you like
who's doing something important who
you're learning from who's paying you to
gain experience connections contacts so
when you launch your business you'll be
ready to go and take on the world so
there's nothing wrong with working for
somebody else while you're launching
your business and I actually highly
recommend it believe who's be watching
like the video please give a thumbs up
below let me know what you think leave a
comment you have a question if it below
make a video response your feedback is
awesome for me I love seeing it coming
every day so thank you so much
and I'll see you soon